hello and welcome Wow that I didn't want
to do I'm sorry for the sound and
welcome to this video I get this again
back to back but black and I was playing
a better variation not something that is
so so bad yeah there should be two is my
choice you have it there are a couple of
things that you can do okay yeah so this
is what black is doing is the simplest
way to handle the position but not bad
like just says okay I'm going for this
standard Caro set up with a 66 it's like
super solid and yeah black has trade the
two pairs of minor pieces which is quite
helpful and then you try to probably
play a bit against the default pawn
let's see how I can do the same black
will often play c5 or II my development
is a little bit slow here I have the
same and I wonder how I should handle
this
maybe with Bishop f4 and then Bishop g5
yeah that doesn't really help
generally speaking g3 King g2 is quite
desirable you have a better background
situation you have Bishop f4 on the
agenda but I'm really a bit slower in my
development Bishop f4 this Bishop d6 and
he has this Bishop takes g3 option hmm I
don't think I played it played it well
iam with E 5 or c5 black should probably
equalize and preparing Bishop f4 now I
came it doesn't really do much Bishop d6
I should probably do this differently
here what what what to do now see if I
can I can always take I just wonder if I
can somehow provoke a little bit of a
weakness somewhere c-45 is tough to play
as default always attacked
okay I'm trying a different approach
Bishop f4 Bishop d6 Bishop e5 something
like that yeah that is definitely
definitely possible that's a good square
okay I'm trying to complete my
development Bishop d2 look 81 Bishop c1
you want to play in a very slow way here
with white at the end ideally getting to
um yeah I don't mind if he would take on
b3 absolutely not I don't think you will
I would be strategically a little bit
dubious nothing special of the same but
it would help me a little bit if he
would take on b3 because then I could
play before and prevents e5 probably
what yto often times just wants to do is
to get into an ending where you can try
to exploit the two bishops you know now
if I get befallen I think I'm quite
happy yeah so I get before and he cannot
go 85 or c5 now if I have I have
prevented so there is no actual way for
black to to ever change the pawn
structure maybe a five he could do at
some point at guca 885 yeah okay mmm
it's there e5
no what I want to do is I had a should
be fine actually what I want to do is I
want to play play the kingside pawns and
gain even more space ideally g4 g5 which
o is helpful
g6 is bad due to age 5 so he has just
like blonde at the tempo no not not a
big deal but it's a it's a tempo so H 5
and then F 4 and G 4 I don't think e 5
is great I have Bishop f5 maybe he could
have done that know that I think of it
okay so ii 5 is that on the cards i have
fish about five but i have to i mean
this is a move that i want to do anyway
I wonder maybe Bishop takes d4 it's not
a thing
it should takes pawn takes rook takes
it's saying yeah I'm a little bit I'm a
little bit tied up there
that is actually quite quite an issue
but sure if I need Bishop f5 against e5
and for this really Bishop takes t4 it's
kind of kind of amazing maybe can play a
5 here and Bishop f5 and it's not clear
that I get anything even walk these six
could be possible
I don't see a good move on against c5
already it didn't do it but didn't see
anything right which is a bit remarkable
yeah yeah I'm I'm just comfortable
unless there is a tactic that I'm
blundering but I don't don't see it
because now I can just push push my
pawns forward g5 I guess I got 15
seconds this is not super comfortable
maybe it was helpful to just let me
protective do you wanna hit once for
once no does that help g6 it could be a
threat quite soon he's dropping down
timewise
push this back I would like to go g6 but
[ __ ] not yet
great g6 is f5 I shouldn't know that hmm
not happy that I had to trade this right
okay g6 is still not good remarkable
I'm straightening major you know let's
invade an mp5 actually discover stuff
since it's annoying I just push the Jeep
on for sure
I can do much him it's probably really
just a draw yeah that's that's really
disappointing and click was somewhat
outplayed but yeah I probably burned too
much time and then I couldn't couldn't
be precise enough like roughly roughly
here I should I should win basically it
just just too much too much
okay Nia was interesting because I
thought there were a couple of moments
where he could play play e5 but somehow
he never did like really when you were
him and I was that was giving me
something but he never played that like
here I went Bishop III a 35 would be
would be a possibility he never played
it I would have played Bishop f5 of
course but I thought like the group d6
would be fine that's a very strong reply
I never I never would have played dead I
guess like just means to walk away
something like that is very nice him
because I have this resource I didn't
really know what to do against d5 if he
would have done that I mean it now it
turns out it is not that great but I
didn't see it
okay so often Knight b5f for this this
is now a very nice warrant I just super
one-sided that like it's just getting
crushed but I couldn't really couldn't
really execute it this is the thing
yeah waiting here okay now is exactly
the moment for g6 okay I went King G for
just like routinely covering I'm going
to do this of course him and then it was
what I wanted to do next but didn't
didn't work the thing is like he cannot
do here cannot take care because of this
this is a disaster Bishop d6 will get
one and yeah I mean back basically as no
movie and you cannot stand even this is
you cannot stand Ruby six seems to be
better but like this is this is hanging
a king g4 I mean it it's it's not the
best but it doesn't spoil and spoil it
all that much okay yeah five was good
yeah I am that that equalizes yeah now
somehow I played it in a way that I had
to trade oops I'm sorry but I had to
trade this 26 which is not really ideal
then probably this is the next mistake
but again he could play e5 yeah I have
to keep the tension down it's a matter
of I have got much more space I have g6
and h6 ideas and of course a much better
minor piece and now after 95 I I don't
know it was a bit difficult really to
not take like with the with the low time
you always feel like you want to avoid
folks and slim things but the king of
three is a lot stronger of course I was
just thinking okay let's take it and I'm
still a little bit better iPhone and
it's easier without having to worry
about about the force but what I really
feel is strange
I shouldn't I should just win the same
and then I think here that looks
terrible absolutely terrible probably
probably I made a mistake there
rookies six and then just bring the King
around you know that this is this is
really really strong I didn't didn't see
it at all the idea is quite remarkable
just this this this and mate that
basically is a made threat in four moves
and that is totally deadly black black
has no way to counter that this is why
it is plus seven there because black but
the engine sees that if you give it more
time I can do this it will go even
higher because you you probably have to
give up the rook for foreign so not much
you know no I didn't see that at all I
was thinking I should run towards the
Queen side which also seems to win but I
didn't do it correctly so he have to
play d4 that secure of cost e5 of course
it doesn't make no sense at all to go
over there just that just get this just
get this going of course the King is
good here I was badly played and after
that it's a draw
after I do this I mean okay I didn't
have much time but it was so easily
played easily improved what I did this
is just like not doing much here he just
pushes chief one that's a draw
I basically lose tons of time that this
King maneuver it doesn't make any sense
okay interesting game though thanks a
lot for watching